take it away doc okay well thank you for
the wonderful information and of course
um I'd like to work with RFK so if all
of you would send him a message saying
hey Doc wck can help you get all this
stuff done um uh he's been talking about
it for what 50 years 75 years and so now
we got somebody in a high place who's
interested in the same thing we are so
everybody should send him an email
um or some kind of letter or something a
text let him know that we're prepared to
help him
okay so anyway
um we still have to take the 90 cents
neutrons I have a great story um Fred
vanl you know we've been working with
him for a long time and he's had a
problem um with um stuff going on in his
legs and so on and he's been taking you
know all the usual stuff vitamin D and
some calcium and not making much
progress but he took the rise and the um
what restore right and he took them for
two weeks in addition to his 90 and all
his leg problems he had for years and
years and years went away and he was so
excited we had a nice talk about it and
so on and then of course um congested
heart
failure um de-stress one of our great
products if anybody has chronic heart
issues okay and also brain issues in
addition to the i26 they should be
taking the de-stress
capsules okay it's amazing when you look
at the dosages of of the ingredients in
this product it'll blow your mind okay
so um let's see here rise
restore d-stress add that to the Healthy
Start pack and
um Healthy Start pack know you kind of
forget about these things but this is
where the 90s started was a Healthy
Start
P okay the
90 okay it's still available we saw a
lot of them okay
economical and has a 90 in it right and
it's one of those things where yeah
there it is right in the
middle pay 90 for life and it has all
the products in there and so this is
easy stuff you don't have to go shopping
all this thing we've already got
everything been doing it for 75 years
okay and then of course we have a new
tool we have a a new DVD it's only a
half hour long it deals with the AI
artificial um
intelligence okay and there's three
people lecturing in here one the guy in
the middle okay is um from Charlie Ward
okay one of the biggest um communicators
in the world okay and so we really
really got a blessing there and of
course um Dr Randy Shannon and myself
each of has about a third of the time on
this like 10 10 12 15 minutes each okay
and it's really a great thing everybody
should think of that of course we have
the DVD and the big CD two hours
DVD and dead do lie because the book was
so popular we came out with a DVD was
one of my best lectures ever two hours
and 10 minutes
long and even the cover is
unique okay
okay for
DVD the doal life it's a DVD goes along
with the
book and um we have it's all in your
head we
have um metabolic syndrome these are all
things the information can add 25 to 50
Health years your life okay and it's one
of those things where
doctors are different than us because
they treat
symptoms and initially people are very
very happy oh my God I suffered with
this for years and doctor gave me this
new drug they had and oh in a week my
pain went
away and then I
died okay because hey Doc what what's
the average life span in America right
now there's Liv Span in America it's in
the 70s like 75 75.7 something like that
and it's gone down a lot oh yeah went
down a lot and of course when you look
at it um arthritis we spend $ 626.
billion dollar a year just to treat the
symptoms of arthritis in America not to
prevent it or fix it but just to treat
the symptoms $26.8 billion who does that
money go to uh uh uh doctors when it
comes to osteoprosis we spend $6.7
trillion and that's with um uh England
okay the
UK and when we add them together is
like8 trillion dollars 8 trillion dollar
we spend for treating the symptoms of
arthritis osteoprosis but not curing it
well it's it's a preventable and curable
disease because of simple nutritional
deficiencies and of course we have our
energy drinks we got a rebound oh my
gosh let me tell you this is there's 30
of these sticks in a
box this is there still time to give
these gifts okay for the
holidays
okay uh there's 30 of these sticks in a
box so I have to go through two of these
boxes I have to pay for them just like
everybody else does I don't get them for
free and then we have
the let's see here it's a
triple triple Bliss okay which is a
chocolate
and all kinds of spice okay on top of
the chocolate I like to take one or two
of those a day and then the triple
truffle chalk I don't take those at
night I take them during the day triple
truffle and they come like I think
there's 30 or 40 in a box of these
things this is a triple
Bliss and here's a triple
Shuffle so these are great things to
give
as birthday birthday presents um
marriage gifts gifts for graduation or
getting a good grade of
school um getting rid of a long chronic
problem it's one of those things where
why would you
not why would you not
take these
nutrients because they're giving your
body what it needs to maintain so if you
think about it you spend spend more time
money and
energy on your car and looking at all
the dials on the dashboard of your car
than you do taking care of yourself and
so that's why we came out with these
books we have I I don't think it's like
27 bestselling books now okay and so
it's one of one of those
things
where if you follow the
directions and do the things that that
are backed by
billions and trillions of dollars worth
of spending from research in
universities and even private
companies why would you not do that well
my doctor says well your
doctor isn't taught this stuff the
doctor's only taught how to relieve
symptoms which makes you very happy okay
and then you
die you have you have the capacity to
live well
beyond 125
150 200 300 even in the old Bible so why
did that change well it changed when
they when Thomas Edison flipped a switch
on
electricity at 3:00 in the afternoon
Monday September 4th
1882 because we've been for thousands of
years it's in the old Bible the land
flowing with milk and honey they were
created by people putting the wood ashes
and coal ashes um into their Gardens and
into their food but also the people who
lived be 120 and so forth they lived in
places is where the Glaciers are
grinding up the mountains and the White
Rock Dust gets in the streams and it
looks like milk coming down the side of
the mountain so the land flowing with
milk and honey okay that's where they
came from right now the longest live
peoples on Earth are the pakistanis
their average lifespan is 122 our
average lifespan in America is 75 except
for emergency room doctors medical
doctors in America is
55.7 not very good that's because they
just live on snack foods and soft drinks
because they're up all night you know
dealing with accidents and people's
sickness and so on and they're not
taking supplements and they're not
taking care of
themselves so with all that said um I'll
turn it back over to you Charmaine
because we can go wherever you want to
go
here okay oh there's a lot of places I'd
like to go but uh I get you and I get in
trouble too much for doing things we're
not supposed to St things we're not
supposed to say right
yeah now I remember my God I could write
a book about all our adventures over the
years it's really been a a roller
coaster ride to put it simply right yep
but anyway I feel like we have just
begun though I mean after what 30 some
years with you we still have a lot to go
and there's a a lot of new young people
that are you know getting into their 20s
now that don't have a clue about how and
if they rely on the doctor they're going
to be sell themselves short and so again
it's our job to get out there and try to
preach to the people that want to listen
I look at this a lot like going to
church I mean there's the health is so
much stuff to talk about and it's the
Bible's so big and so a lot of times if
you go and go and go you're going to
hear the same thing over again but
sometimes you need to hear it over again
so you remember at butter and uh well
you should everybody should be giving
the 90 essential nutrients to their
loved ones or neighbors or workmates or
church mates or pastors um people who
they follow on Sports get them on the
healthy body start pack get them on the
90 and this has been around for a long
time because it works okay well well it
works and you know the thing of it is
the end of January toward the end of
January Med beds are going to come out
and Med beds it's kind of like an
advance of a MRI machine you go in a
like a cocoon it sprays an antiseptic on
you put you to sleep and it will
cure cancer in three minutes it's going
to put the pharmaceutical companies out
of business and you can see why they're
trying to bump prump off because they
know what's coming it's their end it's
their demise but my point is so you can
go in a medbed and get rid of all your
problems you can get rid of diabetes you
can get rid of cancer you can get rid of
Alzheimer disease you can get rid of
dementia everything but between your
medbed visits you better be taking your
vitamins your minerals and your amino
acids or you're going to end up worse
off than you start out and that's what
we got to try to teach people it's not a
magic cure to go in and get rid of all
these diseases but you want to prevent
them in in the meantime it's just like
uh years let me interrupt you here
you're exact you're exactly right
sharmaine people have to take the 90
essential nutrients and then many of
these other issues will work better okay
our body
if you got no arthritis you know no
dementia no anything and you no cancer
no diabetes you want to keep taking your
supplements every day because you know
the stuff is not in the food they put
NPK in the fertilizer and that's it very
few there's a couple of farmers doers
Frozen Foods well when we went to
electricity Char when we went to
electricity that was the end of minerals
getting into our food because they
weren't putting wood ashes and coal
ashes into the gardens anymore well
there's certain frozen food companies
that make the farmers put the humic
shell our humic shell from that comes
from the mine where we get ours they
make them put that in the vegetables and
fruits or they won't buy them but there
you don't know when you eat food if it's
got the minerals in it or not that's the
point I mean
obviously they don't all do it and it
costs money to put minerals humic shell
in the food in the ground uh we put it
we put it in our grapes and when before
we had our our uh what do you call it
poison thing happen to our grape Vines
we had more grapes we had more grapes up
at our Vineyard there than anybody we
had more grapes than we even could
use um before they got some kind of
disease but the point being is the
minerals the humic shell really makes a
big difference but unless you grow your
own food and put it in there you don't
know what's in the food that you're
eating you have no idea and you might as
well assume that there's not much right
sure plants only need three minerals we
need
60 exactly and again you know where I
live I would have to build a greenhouse
to grow my food because animals get it
all I have a big cherry tree and my
carpenter has seen many cherries on my
cherry tree but we've never got one
Cherry the birds get them all I'm not
I'm not saying that's bad the birds got
to eat too but I bought a flat of uh
strawberries once I got one strawberry
out a whole flat the birds and the
rabbits and everybody got all the
strawberries I never I got one
strawberry out of a whole FL
so the point being is I need to have a
garden Outdoors for the animals and I
need to have a greenhouse indoors for
the
humans and uh I think it's a good idea
for people to start growing their own
food because it's the only way you're
going to know what's in it and that way
we can make sure we fertilize it with
real
minerals and it makes a big difference I
know so many people that grew fruits and
vegetables and put the minerals in it
and everybody that ate the food could
tell the difference it tastes different
it it it tastes better grows better it's
more healthy and healthy plants do not
attract bugs I found out that farmers
also so it's I think it's a good idea
for a lot of us to go back to Nature
again and I plan on building a
greenhouse down where I I got 20 acres
so I got room to build a greenhouse and
and become a farmer and uh put the I'll
put the humic shell on my food
definitely I will because I know I know
it makes a big difference and I know
when I eat food it'll be worth something
it'll have some value
to so and I will still take my
supplements obviously because that's the
only way you know for sure what you're
getting is to is to manually physically
take it so and I'm already beat the
average lifespan I'm going to be 82 in
the spring on my next birthday so I'm
and you don't look like you're 82 you
only look
like you're you only look like you're 50
you don't look like you're oh I look a
little than that but but Martha put that
zto machine on me the new one with the
camera and it said I had the skin of a
61 year old I
know that's 20 years younger than I
really am so it could have been the
other way around it could have been like
a 91 year old but it was 61 61's a lot
better than 91 so so it definitely makes
a difference and and those machines they
don't lie they tell the truth they don't
care who they offend right that's
right the healthy body Star Pack the
premier nutritional set of all of
youngevity this contains Dr Wallock 90
essential nutrients it is his 50 years
of research in showing that when you
feed your body the foundational
fundamental nutrients that it needs on a
daily basis it's going to have
incredible Health now the healthy body
start pack has three products it has the
Beyond Tangi Tangerine which is your
multivitamin multi-mineral amino acids
probiotics it has the Beyond Osteo
effects which is your bone and joint
cartilage to ligaments and tendons this
has your calcium and your magnesium and
other things and then you have your
essential fatty acids your omega-3 your
Omega 6 your Omega 9 really hard to get
from foods but you get it from the
ultimate EFA plus so these three
nutrients combine in a very
comprehensive fashion to give you all
the nutrition that you need so you can
take this various times during the day I
like taking my BTT first thing in the
morning I mix it with 16 22 ounces of
water as much water as I can CU I love
the hydration but you can put it in 8
ounces it doesn't matter how much water
that you put it into it's all about you
enjoying the nutrition secondly the
essential fatty acids I take with my
food CU it's always great to take
healthy fat with other food that has
healthy fat you get better absorption
and then the Beyond Osteo effects I take
at night time about 30 to 45 minutes
before I go to bed because those
minerals also help with better sleep so
this is a really great nutrient set that
is for everybody it's you can take it
either by weight or you can take it by
the degree of health issue that you have
so if you're dealing with some health
issues you can take more of it because
we all know the more nutrition that you
get the greater Health that you will
have and lastly you want to make sure
that if you're sensitive to taking
nutrition that you do it slowly so you
may take half of a dose for the first
seven days and then you may build up to
a full dose later on it's okay it's just
getting to that full dose at some point
and making sure that you are working
with your body and making sure that it's
acclimating all the way through so enjoy
your healthy body start pack
introducing our most advanced
nutritional support 3.0 rise and 3.0
restore by youngevity this all new
two-part formulation builds upon almost
30 years of research and success of our
Legacy nutrition products this is BT 3.0
but with a new identity to highlight the
inclusion of targeted support
ingredients for an even more robust
supplement the new 3.0 rise and restore
boosts Health around the clock using
time duration nutrition for better
absorption and utilization of each
ingredient this dual system goes beyond
vitamins and minerals to provide
targeted support for things important to
all of us like cognitive Health stress
defense mood wellness and more designed
to be taken specifically in the morning
and evening rise and restore gives you
exactly what you need when you need it
for Max maximum health
benefits formulated with more Whole
Foods and plant-based ingredients this
system is the most comprehensive
nutritional support ever offered by
youngevity Rise is gluten-free and
vegetarian friendly and features neut
Tropic cognitive support with Energy and
Metabolism boosting ingredients as well
as mood boosting components it also
provides phytonutrients for everyday
antioxidant and immune support and
cellular hydration support restore is
also gluten-free in vegetarian and
friendly designed with restorative
nutrients to help your body recover from
the day stressors featuring circulation
and cardiovascular support ashwagandha
for relaxation and stress relief detox
support preand probiotics for good gut
health as well as an adaptogenic blend
for reducing stress anxiety and fatigue
together these Innovative
research-driven formulas provide a full
circle approach to daily foundational
nutrition for an active life all in
great tasting new flavors that make make
this product an easy lifestyle addition
you'll look forward to each day to help
set the tone for productive days and
restful nights as research continues to
identify opportunities to improve health
youngevity will be at the Forefront of
those discoveries our mission has always
been to support your overall health now
we're going even deeper to Target and
support your Optimal Health wellness and
happiness welcome to a new era in
youngevity nutrition
[Music]